I think this class is
pretty special for one.
It's one of the few courses in the world
that's actually about human emotions
that's actually getting into the
trenches to understand why we are these
emotional creatures that we are.
So what we're trying to do is get students
exposed to a broad variety of issues
that cut across many disciplines.
So these are disciplines ranging from
psychology to neuroscience to linguistics,
even to things like computer
science and even to art and music.
So we're going to be approaching emotion
from a whole variety of perspectives.
And by doing this,
we'll be able to really answer
some fundamental questions
about what we feel and
why we feel it.
So we'll look at what is an emotion?
Where do emotions come
from in the first place?
Are we born as emotional creatures,
or is this something we
learned through experience?
And can we learn how to actually control
our emotions and use them to build
healthier, happier, and I would
hope more meaningful lives too.